i messaged you about this and it seems
to be
one of the most pressing questions
around
the question of metaphysics in the sense
of
how is it possible that a
pattern of activity like a seed
contains all of the trunk the branches
the leaves the fruits
and then it is also recursive as it has
more
seeds how does a zygote contain the
embryo the baby the child the adult
and the potential for more humans
recursion
how does the big bang contain all the
matter stars planet civilizations
and the potential for more big bangs
recursion
and there's no dna during cosmogenesis
that dictates this morphological
development so the question
we ask is what is the information what
is the pattern the underlying habits
unfolding
across these examples how does it work
rupert how does it relate to
morphic resonance well there are many
forms in nature
atoms are forms molecules of forms
crystals reforms plants and animals
planets stars galaxies
all of these are forms in the sense that
they're organized self-organizing
structures of activity
and clearly at the moment of the big
bang there were no forms the universe
was totally amorphous
um so all these forms have come into
being
as the universe has evolved and the same
is true of an egg i mean the big bangs
like the hatching of cosmic egg
um it's kind of mythic the modern
scientific myth
um but if you think of an embryo a
zygote a fertilized egg
um that doesn't contain much form either
and yet you and i have eyes and legs and
arms and spleens and livers and so on um
none of those are in the fertilized egg
more forms appear
so both in individual development
ontogeny and
in phylogeny that evolution of life and
indeed of the entire cosmos
more forms appear from less now
in the case of living organisms like us
then the forms that appear are
repetitions of what's happened before
every time an oak tree grows it's like
previous oak trees
you and i are like previous humans in
many respects
um the every time a new star forms it's
like lots of other stars
so there's one aspect of formation which
is repetition and morphic resonance is
really a theory of repetition and habit
it says that once new forms have
appeared
the more often they appear the more
likely they are to appear again
um so that helps to explain form
uh the appearance of repetitive forms
and after all most things we see are
repetitive it doesn't explain the first
time
an oak tree appears the first time
there's a feather the first time there's
an eye
the first time there's a star or galaxy
or a zinc atom or a
hemoglobin molecule so
there has to be an evolution as well a
principle of creativity
um a creative principle whereby new
forms
new patterns can appear we know they do
appear
um now how we explain creativity is
a big mess physical question and there
are several alternative answers to it
um i leave it open because it depends
very much on people's
world view if you're a materialist and
you think there's nothing but matter
and chance uh giving rise to the
universe then
there's no higher purpose in anything is
just trance
and um but if you think there's a
guiding
consciousness under underlying the whole
of nature the whole of the universe
then there could be creative mind or
minds at work in this process
i'm not talking about a kind of
intelligent design where it's all done
in a kind of like an engineer on a
drawing board
i'm thinking more of a creativity that
spontaneously takes place that
makes things up as it goes along anyway
that's another theory of creativity
but basically morphic resonance is a way
of explaining the repetition of forms
and what i'm suggesting is that the dna
that's inherited in the zygote
has a limited role in inheritance it
doesn't do everything most people assume
that
genetic is synonymous with hereditary
it isn't um what the dna does is enables
organisms to make particular proteins it
specifies the sequence for amino acids
and proteins
like in your hemoglobin or in the
keratin in your skin and so on
you need proteins and all the enzymes we
have um
dna explains that kind of inheritance or
at least the primary structure of these
proteins
there's also epigenetic inheritance the
inheritance of acquired characters which
affects the expression of dna
of genes but most of the inheritance of
form and of instincts
um i think is working through morphic
resonance through this kind of
collective memory principle
excellent okay so let's
let's play off of where we
in a sense it was it's it feels as
though it's a little bit like
uh plato's theory of forms and ideas to
a certain
extent and also it feels as though
there is a a deep
connection between that and what you
were mentioning regarding creativity and
imagination and also the
uh as john von neumann called the the
universal constructor
and so there there's something that
that is inherent in
the cosmogenesis that then
downstream creates
these mutations in the tape that then
which we as co-creators we
influence those mutations at
one moment the imaginative idea of
seeing
birds and then thinking we should fly
across oceans too
and then all of a sudden every
generation
after that has access to flying across
an ocean
in half a day um so
we make these mutations along
along the way and it's almost as though
it's a it's a
forms and ideas and imagination and
creativity that cause that
okay okay well you see i think
what plato was saying is that there's a
realm of forms or ideas that gives rise
to everything in this world they're a
reflection of ideal archetypes or forms
however um he thought those i archetypes
were totally
transcendent in a kind of mind beyond
universe
what i'm saying is closer to what his
student aristotle thought
aristotle thought that the forms were
actually within nature they were the
souls of living things
so for plato every horse is a reflection
of an eternal horse idea beyond
space and time for aristotle every horse
has an invisible horse soul which shapes
its body as it grows as an embryo and
underlies its instincts and so all the
so it's not outside nature is in nature
and for him
soul was a natural causal organizing
principle
every living thing had a soul and he
thought that many things were alive
including magnets
and the earth and the stars um
so what aristotle was saying is closer
to what i'm saying is within
nature and it's um but he
like plato didn't think in terms of
evolution this is a much more recent
idea
um so the idea that they didn't
think in terms of a memory in nature
they didn't need a memory in nature if
you've got an eternal
forms outside nature or inside nature
that are fixed already
you don't need a memory you just take
that for granted
but if things are changing as time goes
along as the evolutionary model suggests
uh indeed it's basic to it then the idea
of memory becomes much more important
because
these forms are not just
manifestations of eternal ready-made
forms
they're based on adaptations to what
actually happens
organisms are shaped by their
environment and they can inherit
adaptations
and um so it's not just an eternal
principle